era 1993
estábamos ante una posible guerra
yo era el ministro de trabajo de la
argentina
recuerdo largas horas de reunión con el
presidente con el resto del gabinete
pensando qué políticas articular para
sacar al país adelante al mantenerlo en
paz
mi desafío como ministro de trabajo era
mantener el nivel de desempleo lo más
bajo posible
me reuní con sindicatos reuní con
empresas
fue muy duro fue muy difícil pero lo
logramos
esta es una foto de mi paso por el
gobierno
acá está tu ministro de trabajo
en 1993 yo tenía sólo 15 años y esta
experiencia se la debo a hernán mi
profesor de educación cívica de tercer
año de secundaria
hernán tuvo un efecto transformador en
mí
cuando él daba clases yo sentía que me
hablaba a mí solo y estoy seguro que
todos sentíamos lo mismo
me acuerdo de hernán sus preguntas como
nos hacía pensar pero sobre todo al tipo
cuando hablaba
el tipo cuando hablaba le brillaban los
ojos
el premio por haber mantenido al país
estable en calma fue ir a comer afuera
un día a la noche yo no lo podía creer
y tuve que pedir permiso a mamá el
ministro de trabajo le tuvo que pedir
permiso a su madre para salir hasta tan
tarde
esas pizzas no me las voy a olvidar
jamás hablamos del colegio hablamos de
las materias pero también hablamos de
los desafíos que teníamos por delante
y como abrazarlos fue la primera vez que
alguien me habló del trabajo de la
facultad
algo que hasta ese momento no estaba en
mí de pronto apareció y sentí muchas
ganas de vivirla
estoy seguro que todos tuvimos un
profesor que nos dejó una marca que
siendo igual a otros no lo fue
cierra los ojos un segundo acuérdense
ese profesor de esa profesora
cómo se llamaba
qué te decía
como te hizo sentir
ahora los
por haber tenido a hernán como profesor
fue creciendo en mí la necesidad de
hacerme cargo de la realidad que veía
mientras crecía y me di cuenta de que
uno no merece de las oportunidades que
uno no merece las enormes oportunidades
que tenemos en la vida si no es capaz de
luchar para que otros también las tengan
yo a eso le llamo educación
y entonces con esa convicción con esas
ganas hace seis años con un grupo de
amigos desarrollamos enseña por
argentina
es un movimiento donde jóvenes
profesionales enseñan por dos años en
las escuelas con más necesidades
ellos son abogados ingenieros
economistas este año están licenció en
biotecnología a quienes elegimos por sus
excelentes notas en la universidad por
su desempeño académico pero también y
sobre todo por su capacidad para motivar
para liderar
queremos sumar mucho talento y pasión a
la educación
en estos años que llevo caminando la
educación me di cuenta de que hay
algunas características comunes que
hacen a estas personas especiales como
hernán con los profesores en los que
pensamos recién
pero cuáles son
que los distingue verdaderamente
obviamente el compromiso
el compromiso hoy ya no alcanza es el
piso sobre el cual construida
y los distinguen su sentido de
posibilidad donde todos los chicos
pueden aprender es incuestionable
y los distingue su sentido de urgencia
donde cada minuto cuenta también es
incuestionable
pero enseña en una escuela en san
fernando
en el último año tiene alumna que se
llama alicia
galicia no vidente
a pesar de tener una maestra integradora
que la acompaña y la ayuda no logra
seguir el ritmo del resto de sus
compañeros
pero hace un enorme esfuerzo para
planificar y adaptar sus clases pero se
da cuenta que no sabe es que allí se
aprende no entre otras cosas el proceso
de corrección tarda mucho en volver a
ella
y un día piensa y sea
el problema no es delicia el problema es
mío soy sola que no puedo leer lo que
allí se escribe y produce en braille
entonces con la ayuda de los largos
viajes de vuelta a la escuela todos los
días y una aplicación que es trabajo en
su teléfono celular en tres semanas
aprendió brasileras razonablemente bien
y ella me cuenta que volvía durante esas
tres semanas todos los días a su casa y
agarraban los trabajos que tenía de
alice y los corregía iba aprendiendo y
se daba cuenta cuánto mejor trabajo iba
a poder hacer ya que analice una vez que
avanzara un poco más y esas tres semanas
pasaron rápido hasta que llegó un día
donde ella se sintió segura
y cuando había terminado la clase y
todos tenían que devolver sus trabajos
la miro al y se le dijo hoy tu trabajo
pero corrigió
si es un gran silencio en el aula
en 12 años será la primera vez que alice
escuchaba esas palabras
la emoción que sintió alicia en ese
momento yo no sé les puedo describir en
palabras
ella les contó al resto de los chicos
que había pensado como había aprendido y
como eso estaba seguro iba a ser caricia
y en definitiva todo el resto del grupo
avanzara
y pasó algo que ni alicia liberó ni
nadie esperaba
adoro braille se volvió algo cool en el
grupo
y adivinen quién estaba ahí enseñando
quién era la maestra quien se volvió
verdaderamente especial
alice
entonces eso tuvo un gran impacto en
ella y en el resto de sus compañeros
esta historia me enseña qué
no hay imposibles en educación hay
urgencias hay que animarnos a abrazar
las
pero hay otro par de características que
hacen estas personas verdaderamente
especiales y es la capacidad de
potenciar potenciales animarnos como
profesores a dar ese paso adelante hacer
modelos de los chicos con todo lo que
eso implica y al mismo tiempo la
capacidad de inspirar qué significa
saber cuándo salió del centro y darles
todas las herramientas a ellos para que
ellos sean los protagonistas de sus
sueños
martín pincho enseña en la escuela
nocturna en villa soldati
tiene un alumno que se llama brian
bryant tiene 16 años
no estaba muy comprometido con su
educación no va llega tarde se repitió
un año
en un momento pincho le dice brian hasta
que llegamos tenemos que hacerlo juntos
te propongo que vengamos los dos una
hora y media antes de cada clase yo te
voy a enseñar sólo a vos y en dos meses
vamos a preparar un examen extra un
examen bonus y vamos a sacar esta
materia adelante juntos
bryant entendido mucho de lo que estaban
hablando pero como confiaba en su
profesor le dijo que sí y trabajaron muy
duro
durante esos dos meses muy dura
y llegó el día del examen
y no apareció
la clase siguiente tampoco apareció son
la tercera clase un viernes
bryant entra laura sin decir nada se
acerca a tinto y le dice
profes prof estuve preso
vos sabés profe que yo a veces salgo de
gira salí de gira estaría robar
salimos con mi primo y mi amigo y
teníamos apuntada a una farmacia y los
agarraron profe nos regalaron a palos y
estuve preso hasta el miércoles y por
eso no pude venir
entonces centro de lo primero que le
dijo es está muy mal lo que estás
haciendo
por qué
sustentó pero hace unos mangos para
llevar a casa
15 le dijo estoy muy muy muy
desilusionado todo lo que pusimos acá
pero estoy dispuesto a darte otra
oportunidad si vos estás dispuesto a
darte otra oportunidad yo estaba
hablando del examen
y prepararon dos semanas más ese examen
que dirá un duro de vuelta
en el examen bryant llegó más temprano
que nadie y entró al aula y pintó me
cuenta que se dio cuenta que hay algo
que no estaba bien porque presentó como
pálido como temblando
y sin poderle decir nada lo abrazo
y casi llorando le dijo tres palabras
profe gracias gracias gracias
porque yo estoy acá pero el viernes
pasado fue mi cumpleaños y mi primo y mi
amigos me vinieron a buscar
porque teníamos que volver en los
códigos del barrio cuando sales a robar
y no robas tenés que volver y como era
mi cumpleaños lo que sacamos me lo
quedaba todo yo
y yo me acordé de ustedes profesor
me acordé de el costo-beneficio me
acordé que usted me dijo que había que
darle una hoja trazada al medio y poner
de un lado lo que yo sacaba cada vez que
salía de gira que eran dos mil pesos y
por otro lado tenía que poner cuánto
valía mi vieja tenía que poner cuánto
valía 25 30 años trabajando porque
profeso tengo amigos míos que trabajan
que ya tienen 16 7 años y ganan 6 mil 7
mil pesos y profe me acordé que usted me
dijo que pregunté cuánto vale mi vida me
acuerdo ese ejercicio que hicimos y yo
note ese número
entonces volvió a usted les dije que no
que me quedaba piola con mi vieja
festejando el cumpleaños
y los chicos salieron
en mi amigo lo mataba en un profe
y mi primo está allí luchando por su
vida y yo estoy acá y lo único que
quiero es dar ese examen y que me vaya
bien y quiero pasar el año y quiero
tener la vida que usted me dijo que yo
podía tener una vida feliz una vida que
yo me merezco
esta historia
a mí
me dice que no una charla pero si una
persona te pueden cambiar la vida te
pueden dejar una marca
y admiro la capacidad de tincho para
haber potenciado e inspirado la historia
de brian y no puedo esperar a ver a
bryant en 5 en 10 en 20 años y ver en la
persona en la que se convirtió
cuando estas características se dan
estos casos se multiplican
enseña para argentina puede ser un canal
para que muchos chicos como brian como
alicia se encuentren con profesores que
dejan una marca grossa en la vida
y puede ser un lugar donde profesores
profesores con mucha experiencia con
mucho olor a aula con mucho conocimiento
de los chicos inspiren y a la vez se
habían inspirado
por los más jóvenes
pero sobre todo puede ser un lugar donde
creemos liderazgos que trabajan en el
red y que a partir de estas experiencias
se comprometan de por vida
sin justicia que hoy afectan a los
chicos que más nos necesitan
hace un tiempo fernando un director de
la escuela en el bajo boulogne donde
trabajamos me dijo oscar sabes qué es lo
que más me impresiona de tele tenés una
profe enseña por argentina yo pensé que
me iba a decir cómo te lee planificado
las clases que lo hacía muy bien como
llevaba actividades innovadoras en el
aula como conocí a cada uno de los
chicos
con los que compartía todos los días
pero no me dijo algo que yo no esperaba
o tal vez sí
dijo lo que más impresiona de tve
cuando ella da clases
le brillan los ojos
inmediatamente me acordé de hernán mi
profesor de educación cívica del colegio
y me di cuenta que la educación esa
educación transforma gracias
[Aplausos]